[Music]
now the question is people who ask this
one's for you snoop where did the
inspiration for your community garden
project mind gardens stem from it's
different from me seeing people in
Jamaica
poor not having anything to eat and not
having any means to create food so I got
with a friend of mine and we created a
program called mind gardens to take the
people of Jamaica and showed them how to
grow produce and produce the produce
salad and eventually eat it and take
care of themselves boy we should have
that here we could use that here but I
saw in the movie I mean you were in
Kingston they're very very poor
neighborhoods but you were greeted like
a like you were the Saviour yes yeah
Rastafari Monica do you think there is
it different today between capitalism
and corporate greed well I think
capitalism is more of an ideology and
corporate greed is more of a real
philosophy um I think capitalism is that
what they're getting at their court when
they call corporate cronyism er you know
I think cronyism exists in politics I
think it exists in religion I think it
exists in any place where you have
people with money and power and the idea
of capitalism the idea that you can take
something something and make it bigger
and someone starts from zero and can can
go to a bigger place
I think that's healthy there's room for
there's room for obstructing the system
and taking more than you need to take
but at the end of the day I think it
still works and I think it's American at
it's very core capitalism is an American
I think it works and it's good well it
definitely works better than the
opposite I always say it's like a river
you know you don't try to make the river
flow in the opposite direction that's
communism but a river does need dams and
locks on it or else it overflows the
banks everything needs balance
everything you go
all right Steve Schmidt is it possible
you pick Sarah Palin the wrong year oh
my
could she have swung the woman vote in
2012 enough to have put Romney in the
White House and no no no no no never
your feeling is there is never a good
time for Sarah Palin now what do you
think she's learned anything in the
years since
no all right Gavin what do you say you
would why do you say you admire the Tea
Party's level of active engagement and
effectiveness I agree with you there's
no I just an amazing I I admire people
step up and step in and the fact is they
have been effect and how quickly they
did exactly and he's still effective in
my biggest fear about what's going on
right now is their effectiveness you
think about Ted Cruz guy comes out of
nowhere and now you've got corn in the
number two most powerful Republican
senator from Texas who is now under
quote unquote cruise control because Ted
Cruz has got this guy's sight because
corn and scared to death he may be
primary by the tea party in Texas so
Cornyn can't be himself it's just an
example over example or example Rand
Paul and others of the impact these guys
are still having and so on one level
can't stand it don't like what these
guys are offering another level there's
something to the kind of advocacy and
promotion and interact the Tea Party's
having that rights to pick up I've got
to give him credit just for that
organization because they were not even
in politics all the time Bush was
president you know the people who
supposedly care so much about the debt
well whatever
while Bush was running up the debt and
didn't pay for anything but as soon as
President blackenstein got elect
suddenly they came out of the woodwork
they organized and they won the 2010 oh
yes and then they went back to the Attic
to have sex with their half-sister okay
James line well computers ever be truly
secure or will hackers always be able to
find a way in even into government sites
I think that the sad reality is you're
never going to get 100% in security
because computers are designed by people
and people make mistakes but you also
got to remember if you look at all these
recent attacks we were talking about
earlier well unfortunately lots of them
work because people double click on
things like funny cats dot exe and
Britney Spears near naked sideways which
confuses me because I always thought
they were the same thing but but right
whose tit fell out of their dress and
you're in is that how they get you they
didn't make you click on you better
watch out for that yes yeah
note to self do you think the Republican
Party is capable of revitalizing itself
within the next few years absolutely I
have been around long enough to see
every time a party is down the media
writes the obituary and this country has
a thing about not letting one country
party fall too low they like the balance
they really do if you've ever seen a
zombie movie don't say don't count them
out completely good that's not mean
remember we went through I mean in not
an indictment but difficult times post
Carter Mondale Dukakis then all of a
sudden the southern governor advancing
the principles under the Democratic
Leadership Council in 91 92 and starts
talking about putting people first more
opportunity less bureaucracy and Bill
Clinton emerges and the party begins to
center itself and we've had this string
and after Nixon the Republicans were
gonna be gone forever and that guy took
like yeah right yeah okay all right
thank you everybody Thank You panel
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10:00
ask bill and his guests or questions
right after the show at HBO calm